ça met d'abord dans la sphère du petit
grégory plus aucun suspect n'est donc
poursuivi par la justice à partir
d'aujourd'hui ni muriel bolle ni les
époux jacob leur mise en examen sont
annulés anne berger on vous retrouve en
direct devant la cour d'appel de dijon
on peut parler and depuis ce matin d'un
véritable coup de tonnerre
ah oui un coup de tonnerre on peut le
dire à une surprise pratiquement un an
après le rebondissement spectaculaire de
cette affaire en juin dernier
même les avocats apparemment ne s'y
attendait pas puisque seul maître ba
lorrains avaient fait le déplacement
était présent à la cour d'appel pour
entendre la décision de la chambre de
l'instruction
je vous propose tout de suite d' écouter
sa réaction l'avocat de muriel bolle et
forcément soulagé et satisfait la
chambre de l'instruction reprend ce que
nous crions depuis déjà quelques mois
savoir que muriel bolle est innocente et
que ni de près ni de loin elle n'est
concerné par l'enlèvement et le meurtre
du petit grégory
une vraie victoire pour vous là c'est
une très belle décision nous allons en
prendre connaissance
c'est effectivement une très belle
victoire pour nous muriel bolle et
innocente sa mise en examen
tombe et bien évidemment son contrôle
judiciaire tombe également muriel bolle
est complètement libre est innocente
voilà et concernant les époux jacob et
bien c'est la même chose plus aucune
charge ne pèse contre eux
la chambre de l'instruction a estimé
qu'elle n'avait pas suffisamment
d'indicés d'éléments de preuve pour les
maintenir en examen c'est un coup dur
pour l'accusation
ça ne veut pas dire que les
investigations vont s'arrêter que le
dossier va être refermée mais ce matin
on a vraiment l'impression que l'espoir
de connaître un jour la vérité dans
cette affaire vieille de 33 ans vient de
s'éloigner encore un peu plus merci anne
verger pour ces précisions